all right Adrien and Tamara where you
guys from
originally La well K really s Gabriel
Valley I'm from Long Beach what were
your childhoods like
um childhood
was it was pretty
dysfunctional
[Music]
um grew up in um well borderline
Lakewood Long
Beach
um well my mom and my dad raised us and
he was a good he was a good parent you
know my dad he worked his ass off to put
put food on the
table and um you know clothes on our
bags um but you know we still found a
way to get into
trouble um sounds like a pretty good
childhood huh sounds like a pretty good
childhood yeah yeah yeah I mean you know
my my my dad was hardworking he was a
hardworking parent but we you know well
I my brothers we still found a way to
like you know to get into
trouble um so yeah the first time I I
committed a crime it was um 9 years old
I was 9 years old and
um yeah we had like
stolen stolen our neighbors um property
after they had moved
out and
um yeah
um distributed to like people on our
block and stuff like
that
um yeah I was terrible
freaking my dad found out about it and
like really whooped our ass you
know uh as far as your childhood goes
there was no no particular abuse or
anything like that that was going on
abuse no basically a good childhood
except you were acting up yeah
yeah there was no no type of no type of
abuse going on at all
um I mean besides when we get in trouble
you I'm saying like we what kind of girl
were you in high school huh what kind of
girl were you in high school in high
school um I
was
um I was I mean I was cool I was really
you know I was cool with everybody um
unless
they you know um
found a way to make me angry or
something like that so I I fought a lot
I got into a lot of
fights
um you know wasn't really wasn't really
too too nice to people that that I
wasn't fond of you know and Adrian um I
grew up really poor um my mom she did
the best that she could my dad wasn't
really around uh my dad had a dream of
being a rock star so he was always in
those nightclubs trying to trying to
make something of himself but he wasn't
get around um we didn't actually have
like a kitchen table until I was like
seven so we had a lot of a lot of
picnics and then um as we got older you
know things kind of got a little bit
better and but my mom always found a way
to kind of like like [__] it up I mean
she was a good mom like you know we
always had we she did her best to have
the food on table clothes on her backs
but she's really neglectful she um she
started [__] my sister's boyfriend
who was beating me and you know she kind
of chose him over all of us and you know
it was really fun [__] up when she
kicked my sister out of the house so
that he could stay there without any
issues and um you know as I tried to
tell her that I was getting beat and you
know she just didn't believe it um your
Mom stole your sister's boyfriend yeah
basically W and uh you know we kind of
just started losing [__] from there um
we went from like we we we grew up
really poor and then as I got older we
kind of my mom got a good job and you
know we moved into like a condo and then
all this [__] happened and we slowly but
surely fell and then when I was 13 this
dude was still living with us and um I
tried to kill him and um you know that's
when he finally moved out and then
beating stopped uh and then I just kind
of started hanging out in the streets
and selling weed and stuff like that
through high school and um just
eventually progressed until I was in
gangs and
[__] um and started doing math what age
was that um I started doing meth at like
19 but i throughout High School from
like 13 to 19 I was doing ecstasy and
drinking and um everything got to got so
bad to a point when I was 15 I tried to
kill myself and um I spent a couple
weeks in the
hospital when did drug use start for you
tomorrow um started when I was around 15
I started getting to the heavy drugs uh
it's a meth and um exstasy
cocaine uh and heroin came when I was 18
I started using heroin
um and yeah fentol got into fentol about
on four years
ago somewhere around there um are you
guys both using fentel yeah yeah I got
into it about two years
ago would you have gotten into fentanyl
on your own doing or do you think it was
just because you were doing opiates and
and Fentanyl became kind of snuck into
the
scene for heroin users yeah know
um well for me it's cuz I well I went to
I ended up going to a program I went to
a program and when I came out I couldn't
find heroin anywhere yeah it's replaced
right
um and then yeah I was introduced to
fentel and um it it was something that I
I honestly I didn't want to get into at
all you know what I'm saying cuz I was
just hearing about how terrible it was
and but slowly but surely I ended up
falling into it
and um yeah it's
been it's been hard to to stay away from
yeah how old are you guys now I'm 32 I
just yeah go sorry we both just turned
um she's 32 she's 32 she turned uh that
on September 19th and I turned 30 on the
10th of this month oh happy birthday
thank you and uh where are you guys
staying oh in our car in my car you're
living in your car yeah MH and you come
down to Skid R because you can get
everything you need basically and I to
shower and um to get meals because
people pass out food and stuff like that
sure uh you know we've been we've been
together about 3 years now and you know
we've had our moments where we got clean
you know what I mean or I'll end up in
jail because I'm trying to take care of
us you know end up robbing somebody or
stealing cars or something you know I
mean CU I'm always constantly in jail
for the better part of our relationship
I've been locked up jail is a great way
to get clean
yeah I mean it's probably like it's the
only way I know how to kick because
we've tried to do a detox a couple of
times and you know just have knowing
that we can leave just you know we end
up leaving oh that's the problem yeah
what what's your relationship like with
your families
now oh I basically I really don't have a
relationship with my family I mean I
haven't talked to my sister in like 11
years my brother I haven't talked to him
like maybe two or three and then my mom
and I'll talk to off and on but the only
one I have a relationship with is my dad
my dad's amazing he's a really good
loving and caring dad I I definitely
don't deserve a dad like him you know I
really want to get clean just to just is
Mak him proud I love my dad a
lot and tomorrow what's your
relationship like with your family uh I
have a good relationship with my family
like when I'm when I'm doing the right
thing um as far as like right now they
don't really know that I'm high again I
just I just recently got out of program
and um um like they know that I'm out
but they don't know that I'm out here
getting loaded again you know so when
they do find out about it it's going to
it's not going to be good and yeah
that's really the only time that I'm I
have issues with my family is is when
I'm
high what emotions do you guys go
through living this
life a lot of guilt and shame you know a
lot of regret and you know hopelessness
some days you know trying to figure out
like what name yeah most days
hopelessness you know it's just it's
about
um not being able to to provide for
ourselves you know on a daily basis and
going through the struggles of that and
um you know we're we're constantly
fighting majority of the time fighting
um but still at the end of the day
there's nobody I'd rather lay next to I
I'd be lost if I didn't I think any two
people would be fighting when you're
going through all the obstacles you guys
are going through now yeah how do you
make
money um honestly because right now I
have two strikes and I'm on a joint
suspension so I'm doing everything I
possibly can to not have to commit a
crime so I've been trying to recycle a
lot and um I'm trying to wait on this
thing with Chrysalis I'm waiting on the
orientation to do it on Monday to try to
help do something you know what I mean
and also I'm trying to get in line with
the uh to get an SRO try to get us off
the streets that would help a lot right
yeah but the only money that we have
coming in right now is for the food
stamps and the gr you know yeah do you
have hope of getting clean one day yeah
definitely I mean
I'm this can't be all there is and know
I mean like we've gotten clean I mean
like she said we were both just in a
program we both just graduated and we
were doing good and you know just I
don't know what the [__] happened we
just fell and we fell fast this time you
know um
you know we we we both want to be clean
you know it's just this is doesn't make
sense knowing that this is where we get
to when we want to get clean and we get
clean knowing that this is what we're
going to end up at we still test the
waters thinking that we can do it yeah
addiction is a hell of a thing it's what
do you think people that don't do drugs
don't understand about drug addiction
it's not that we just can't stop you're
smart enough to know that it's not the
right thing to do yeah I mean like if I
could just stop and never touch this
[__] again I would you know um but it's
not that easy I would you know I wish I
could just say all right I'm done and
just never come back it's not that it's
there's this little demon in the back of
your head that when you're doing good
and everything's fine around you you
just have that voice oh I want to get
high today and that voice you shut that
voice out but it gets louder and louder
and louder until that's the only thing
you can hear yeah and then the next
thing you know you're back up you're
back down here picking up a sack and you
know trying to figure out what you can
collect next to get
high what are your biggest fears
now that I'll go back to prison or one
of us will die you know cuz just
recently I've had to save her like four
or five times now yeah and we've only
been out here for like three weeks this
time OD
yeah you know
um yeah those are my fears car Naran
with you yeah I try not to use it though
because I mean they like I've
ODed three times on on Fentanyl and just
knowing that that pain coming you know
it's it's [__] horrible so I'm lucky
that we both know CPR and how to bring
each other
back yeah he just had to Nar can me the
other day because I had I went out I
overdose andar
Camy it was that was terrible for me and
I never I never had that that experience
before you know and all my years using
i' never been been naram like that
before and it was just it was crazy I
woke up like freaking out just not
knowing what was going on with my body
you
know and yeah it was kind of scary yeah
no you're you're you almost died yeah
and even that still won't get you to
stop right which shows you the power of
of these drugs yeah it does I mean I was
stabbed in the throat and um you know
the first thing I do when I get out of
the hospital I went I came straight back
down here and I slammed a shot of math
this this was before I was starting to
doing iney but you know I was I was in a
relationship with somebody that was on
drugs and you know I try to break up
with this individual and she stabs me in
the throat you know that's what I have
all this from and um the moment I get
out of the hospital straight back down
here with an need lar you know and I
really am almost dying you know be the
lifestyle that I'm choosing live and you
know you really don't understand when
enough is enough like even though you
want it to be enough you know that
always just always there's this itch to
do it one more time I can do it just one
more time and it's never just one more
time do you guys have children yeah I do
I have two boys where are they with
their paternal
grandparents do you talk to them
or um
honestly right now no not really
uh I haven't I
haven't been in contact with my son my
youngest
son um for the last like four
years say um and then my oldest son and
he stays close not too far up South
County
but his grandparents aren't really you
know they're as when I'm using they
don't want me talking to him
or um you know really trying to trying
to communicate like that because he's
getting older now and he's he already
has the understanding of what of using
you know he lost his
dad um when he was 6 years old to the
addiction you know
um
but um basically the older that he gets
the more that he knows and they're not
trying to have me come in and out of his
life like that and to see me doing the
things that I'm doing you know it's it's
just unhealthy and it's it's only going
to hurt him
more is that the hardest part for you to
deal with that your kids are out there
and you're not really in their lives I
mean yeah
it's I mean it's it's hard you
know what are the advantages of being a
couple
and living homeless like you are you're
not really alone though you know I mean
like it because I mean for for a long
time I did this by myself like before I
met her cuz I I met I don't really like
people you know I never really have and
you know so I was used to being alone so
there were days when it was really hard
when I'd give up or you know I didn't
want to do this anymore and I'd make
some stupid really really stupid choices
and um I try to kill myself or something
like that and you know I'd wake up just
to find out that I'm still here or
whatever but you know for me at least
it's just not being alone you know
knowing
that you know I have somebody that that
cares whether I live or die you know to
just have somebody to lay next
to but I mean yeah that's me it's got to
be good to have
somebody just that you trust that's in
your life cuz most people out here you
can't trust right yeah no absolutely
you know even in the position that we're
in you know we we stay by by each
other's side because we TR you know we
trust each other and we we love each
other and
um
and yeah even though it gets hard um you
can still find find comfort in each
other um through the rough times how
long have you guys been together for 3
years three years how'd you meet I was
picking up dope one day and she was um
at my connect um spot smoking and I hit
on her for the first time and she told
me no and um yeah I ended up running
into her again about a week later and
she said no again but as I was about to
leave she stopped me I'm like hey let's
go get something to eat and we just we
have we just was a wrap after that we've
haven't been separated unless I've been
in jail since
then what are the disadvantages of being
a couple on the streets because the
streets are rough down here it makes it
that much harder because you love this
person and you want to see this person
clean but yet you don't want this person
to leave because you'd be alone you know
what I mean and when I sit here and I
look at her and I know that she's
starving or whatever else it is it eats
me up inside because I know that I can
go rob somebody or I can go steal this
car but you know I have two strikes and
I'm on a joint suspension right now if I
commit one more crime I'm not coming
home for like a decade and it Eeps me up
in the side that I'm looking at her
knowing that she's hungry or whatever it
is and there's nothing that I can do you
know what I mean so that's the worst
part for me and the simplistic way of
looking at this is well just quit the
drug use and get a job but that's just
yeah that's just an impossible thing
right now it seems yeah it does you know
I mean like it's [__] up that that
like it doesn't even feel like an option
sometimes you know I mean just to stop
because I know that the moment that I do
stop like getting fent all like okay now
I'm getting sick you know
and the only way I've ever been able to
stop that was going through jail and
even when you get clean in jail then you
still relapse when you get when you get
out that's a vicious cycle you know and
and none of it makes sense none of it
makesense that's why I asked it's like
do you think you'll be in this situation
forever no no I definitely have hoped
that one day soon we'll be able to get
to stop or you know just even B one by
we've tried to do it together so the
only way that we're going to get clean
is if we separate and that's you know
that's the hard part too
M it'd be interesting to separate for
whatever it takes a year or so if you
both got clean and then got back
together seeing how the relationship
would change yeah we I mean we were
clean just recently for what 5 months
together yeah you were yeah how was that
it was really good it was actually
really amazing I had gotten arrested and
um we had just I had given up on the
relationship at that point and I gotten
arested and I found God and um about two
months me me being in jail um I got a
letter on my door from her she had
gotten clean got on
medication and you know we decided to
work on each other work on ourselves
again and it worked out really
well and then just after five months
clean
um she wanted to get use and I was
trying to make sure that it didn't
happen but she told me that either with
me or without me she was going to use
and
so I'm I'm I'm really [__] protective
over her so I left with her so I knew
that she was
safe you know so that's what started all
this
again cuz I didn't want her to be out
here by herself
because I didn't know if she was in to
overdose or whatever it
was what's been the hardest thing you
guys have gone
through she gets her FR you yeah
probably um has it hasn't been too bad
but um you know the years over the years
out here um I became a a a schizophrenic
well
bipolar
schizophrenic and there were a lot of
things that that I believe to be true
that would cause
um cause a lot of
chaos
um you know not just between us but just
every with everybody in my life you know
because I didn't know who was out to get
me um you know I believe that you're
doing things behind my back that
probably weren't even true
um people were stealing my identity like
it's just really like far out far out
things you
know um but yeah
it's
it it cost me to do a lot of things that
I wouldn't normally
do
um
and yeah is that from the drug use or
the lack of sleep or both from from the
drug use yeah and maybe you had a
propensity to go to
schizophrenia yeah like I I think that
like I don't know if
like it was like like a bad you know
what I'm saying a bad batch of dope or
something I I had got my hands on or or
what but
um but yeah definitely drug
induced and Adrian what were you
thinking as you're going through
that oh that was how
um that was a lot of help you know
because I didn't know but I was ever
going to stop you know um like I'm
talking about like like we'd be fine and
then just one moment I would say like a
word and she would go off and start
thinking crazy [__] I remember at 2:30
in the morning one time we were driving
down to 110 she made me pull over pulled
everything out of the trunk and you know
was she was not knocking on the on the
on the where like above where the tire
is Think Like oh it's Hollow right here
she like cuz she thought that I was
hiding a girl in the trunk so that
waiting for her to go to sleep so I
could [__] this girl you know so it was
just it was really difficult and I was
always trying to get her clean and that
was the hardest part about it too
because when I tried to get her clean
she just thought I was trying to put her
in a mental hospital but it was just a a
vicious cycle that everything I was
doing to try to help was just trying to
take something away from her or or
trying to put her into sex slavery or
whatever the [__] it was whatever the
the the trip was that
week and just leaving her wasn't an
option because I knew how bad she was
you know so I always worried that if I
if I would have left her somewhere what
would have happened to her would she
have been raped or killed or would she
have tried to kill herself or you know
so there was days when it was really
hard and I didn't want to leave where I
couldn't stand her and you know in those
days it wasn't just about what I wanted
it's about what I thought she may need
because she couldn't be alone at that
time you know so I just kind of sucked
it up and did my best to make sure she
knew she could trust me and try to get
her
[Music]
clean it's
probably difficult as well knowing that
your your home is
one car problem away from being useless
oh yeah just this morning um our car
died just for um cuz it ran out of I
left the keys in the ignition and it was
on so the battery
died yeah it sucks and then you're
homeless without a 10
yeah I mean but if I if I lost this car
the first thing I would do is I would go
steal another one I mean I mean I
actually own this car this car isn't
like stolen but that's the first thing
that I would do is I couldn't cuz I need
to able to drive I need to be able to
move like but then you risk three
strikes yeah but it' be the first thing
that I
do it's the first thing that I always do
it's a stressful lifestyle yeah
yeah what would you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
lives
see to never thinking that I have a
control over this drug you know what I
mean like cuz to when I get clean again
you know what I mean to not to to never
think that I can control this or that I
can just just do this one more time
because this one more time is going to
lead it's going to lead to death or
[__] life in prison for
me
MH all right you guys thank you so much
for sharing your stories thank you I
wish you lots of luck out here
appreciate it you thank you very
much